[Musik]
guten abend am ende werden wir uns
gegenseitig viel verzeihen müssen hat
der gesundheitsminister
schon am anfang geahnt corona politik
war wie autofahren lernen während die
kiste schon über den nürburgring rast
es war ja so gut wie nichts bekannt
struktur des virus verbreitungswege sinn
und unsinn von schutzmaßnahmen alles
neuland
als dann rekord schnell impfstoffe kamen
stellte sich ihre wirksamkeit auch erst
allmählich heraus
ok for entschuldigungen haben bürger
aber anspruch auf aufklärung warum wurde
zu astrazeneca erst hü dann hott dann
wieder höhe und jetzt was ganz anderes
gerufen kombi impfung
das wird mal zu klären seien aber erst
mal sind die neuen regeln dringender und
müssen überzeugen und ohne termin und
für alle ab 12 jahren auf einem
wochenmarkt bei osnabrück nutzten heute
hunderte dieses angebot für astrazeneca
geimpfte gab es als zweite dosis bayern
tag die möglichkeit hatte sich
kurzfristig aufgetan und die habe ich
dankend angenommen
ich wäre sonst erst mitte august gemacht
worden
eine solche kreuz impfung soll jetzt
allen zur verfügung stehen sie sei meint
der bundesgesundheitsminister die
bestmögliche kombination
jeder der in deutschland zugelassenen
impfstoffe ist sicher ist wirksam hilft
gegen kurve 19
aber dieses impfschema diese kombination
von astra zenica und -männer im stoff
ist besonders wirksam rund vier wochen
sollen zwischen der impfung mit
astrazeneca und einem mp rent a
wirkstoff liegen bereits feststehende
zweit impfterminen müssen jetzt
umgeplant werden für die impfenden ärzte
wird das womöglich schwierig also das
ist natürlich unruhe mit ansagen denn
wenn patienten den ersten ausfahrten
einen impftermin für die zweite impfung
nach neun bis zwölf wochen hat man jetzt
sagen nach vier wochen sollen sie dann
einen hemmstoff bekommen dann müssen sie
ja nicht nur den termin anpassen sondern
müssen auch schauen dass in diesem
zeitraum auch diese mehr dosen er wäre
nach vorhanden sind
ich bin mal sehr gespannt ob das
funktionieren würde habe aber meine
zweifel
der bundesgesundheitsminister meint
dagegen sei genügend impfstoff vorhanden
man sei gut vorbereitet sogar auf
mögliche dritte impfung im herbst in
seiner aktuellen delta variante hat das
virus ein turbo verbreitet sich
schneller hat größere also schlimmere
wirkung einerseits andererseits trifft
das virus jetzt auf fortschritte bei den
impfungen aber sehr unterschiedliche in
deutschland sind 55 prozent mindestens
einmal geimpft in russland sind es 16
prozent
die massiven unterschiede kollidieren
jetzt mit einer fußballmeisterschaft die
ein grenzenloses europa zeigen und
feiern sollte gut gedacht
pech beim timing grenzenlos werden
gerade auch leichtsinn und unvernunft
und die gefahren aus beiden unser
russland korrespondent christian sind
berichtet eine polonaise in der fan zone
so ziemlich das gegenteil von abstand
halten im delta virusvarianten gebiet
allein heute in sankt petersburg 1671
registrierten neuinfektionen fans aus
finnland polen belgien oder der slowakei
und schweden waren schon hier einige
brachten corona mit zurück in die heimat
heute kamen auch fans der schweizer und
spanier
das sind schon geimpft aber ein bisschen
ängstlich bin ich schon aber nicht zu
sehen
wir passen auf vermeiden risiken und ich
hoffe es nicht zu bekommen
das ist ein heikles thema besser bleibe
ich beim fußball wieder angst aber wir
vertrauen dass es uns erspart bleibt
ihnen bleibt es nicht erspart die
krankenhäuser hier am limit
seit einer woche über 100 corona tote in
sankt petersburg jeden tag
die stadt reagierte auf die steigenden
infektionszahlen nun mit kleinen
einschränkungen
neben den em-spielen leben massen events
wie dieses erlaubt letztes wochenende
feierten tausende schülerinnen und
schüler ihren abschluss am ufer der newa
wir haben explodierende infektionszahlen
wir sehen immer mehr kranke leider die
fußball fans reisen jetzt wieder in die
heimat und tragen womöglich nicht nur
die schönen erinnerungen an sankt
petersburg mit sich die nachrichten
beginnen mit einem abschied der den
abschied nehmenden das herz kaum schwer
gemacht haben kann
bundeskanzlerin merkel hat bei ihrem
voraussichtlich letzten offiziellen
großbritannien besuch im amt
premierminister johnson getroffen
nach dem wechsel soll nun ein neues
kapitel in den beziehungen zwischen
beiden ländern aufgeschlagen werden
unter anderem durch regelmäßige
regierungsgespräche im anschluss wurde
merkel von königin elizabeth der zweite
auf schloss windsor empfangen
in afghanistan ist beim abzug der
internationalen truppen
eine weitere etappe abgeschlossen worden
die us und andere nato einheiten haben
nach fast 20 jahren ihrem
hauptstützpunkt die luftwaffenbasis
bagram verlassen und an die afghanischen
streitkräfte übergeben
nach der tödlichen messerattacke in
würzburg haben hunderte mit einer
menschenkette der opfer gedacht nahe dem
tatort reihten sich die teilnehmenden
aneinander
man wolle auch solidarität zeigen mit
jenen die nun vorverurteilung
und hetze ausgesetzt seien vergangenen
freitag hatte ein 24-jähriger somalia
drei frauen erstochen und sieben
menschen zum teil lebensgefährlich
verletzt ein unsinn wird so oft
behauptet dass die wahrheit mal gesagt
werden muss ard und zdf sind kein
staatsmann staat und parteien das schon
mal vergessen haben geräte spätestens
das verfassungsgericht dazwischen die
wichtigsten personalien bestimmen im
grimm die gremien in denen bund und
länder kirchen lesben und
schwulenverbände unternehmer und
gewerkschaften kunst und migranten
jugendverbände und so weiter vertreten
sind 60 menschen aus allen richtungen
heute wählte der zdf-fernsehrat den
nächsten intendanten zwei starke
bewerber/innen eindrucksvolle
vorstellungen offene wahlgänge klares
ergebnis
susanne gelhard berichtet er wird der
neue zdf intendant nach einer spannenden
wahl
norbert himmler zdf-programmdirektor
setzte sich gegen tina hassel die
hauptstadt studioleiterin durch sie zog
zurück nachdem sie in zwei wahlgängen
unterlegen war
wir sind uns sehr einig gewesen dass
diese seine sehr gute wahl ist und wir
kennen herrn dr himmler und wir hatten
einen respektablen gegenkandidaten die
wirklich sich in dieses haus hinein
versetzt hat der intendant oder die
intendantin des zdf wird für fünf jahre
in geheimer wahl gewählt vom
zdf-fernsehrat er vertritt die
interessen der allgemeinheit im zdf
seine 60 mitglieder werden von den
unterschiedlichen gesellschaftlichen
gruppen entsandt die genaue
zusammensetzung ist gesetzlich geregelt
für die wahl sind mindestens drei
fünftel der stimmen erforderlich also 36
57 stimmen bekam norbert himmler ein
kind des zdf wie er von sich selbst sagt
vom redakteur zum medienmanager
digitalisierung reformen sparen der neue
job ist nicht einfach
ich glaube das erst recht in zeiten wo
der gesellschaftliche zusammenhalt im
mittelpunkt steht die information und
die aufklärung ganz ganz wichtig und
essentiell sind
und da ist einer der großen schwerpunkte
die ich setzen möchte im bereich der in
form
aktionen der bildung aber auch der
kultur im kommenden märz wird er sein
amt übernehmen den weg ins büro kennt er
schon
und bevor es gleich mit der zweiten
halbzeit zwischen belgien und italien
weiter geht eine meldung zur deutschen
fußball-nationalmannschaft die spiele
künftig ohne toni kroos der 31 jahre
alte mittelfeldspieler von real madrid
gab nach 106 länderspielen heute seinen
rücktritt aus der nationalmannschaft
bekannt jetzt noch kurz die
wetteraussichten morgen ist es bei 21
bis 27 grad oft freundlich östlich der
elbe sind schauer möglich am abend
westlich des rheins gewitter am sonntag
entladen sich im westen teils heftige
gewitter die neue woche beginnt
wechselhaft und barren
das war schon von uns wir wünschen ein
gutes spiel noch und ein erholsames
wochenende kurzer hinweis auf unser
heute schon ein update mit nacktem er
voraussichtlich gegen 0 uhr wieder sinn
[Musik]